what if I stop making videos I ask my
team what if we only had 30 more days to
make YouTube videos and then that's it
big question right if we only had 30
days left to make YouTube content what
videos would we make that had the
biggest longest lasting impact on the
world so I've been on YouTube for over
eleven years
April 2009 was my first video I've done
over 6000 videos on YouTube
not all of them are public and tomorrow
May 20th I turned 40 years old and so
we're thinking what is the best way in
these 30 days to have this biggest
impact possible best live 30 is the
answer so every day for the next 30 days
I'm gonna create a video that is
specifically designed and tailored to
help you get the momentum that you need
and the push forward in your life I'm
also including some free pdf companion
worksheets that go with every video so
as you watch a video does the free pdf
that you can use so that you get the
most of the video and you actually make
the shift that you need in your life if
you want to make sure you're not missing
a single video into 30 days and get the
bonus companion worksheets is a link
down the description below go click on
it sign up for free and we start
tomorrow so 30 days to change your life
30 days to overcome the doubt the fear
and the confusion 30 days to become the
version of you that your family and the
world deserves you are gonna join me on
a life-changing journey you'll get
mentored by some of the smartest most
accomplished most inspiring people on
the planet you'll have the chance to
make the changes that you need to make
in your life your heroes are going to
push you to transform and evolve into
the person you know you're capable of
being it's 100% free the videos will be
here live on my youtube channel starting
tomorrow again if you want to make sure
that you don't miss a single day and get
all the bonus companion worksheets PDFs
for free there's a link the description
go click it sign up today and we start
tomorrow
now what's included what are we cover it
in best live 30 all of the messages and
content
I've been handpicked by myself and my
team we have watched over a hundred
thousand videos over the past 11 years
to build my YouTube channels we have
over 300 million views on the channels
have run data and analytics from over
6,000 videos and have run countless
tests and combinations to find the exact
message is needed for you to get lasting
change best live 30 is divided into six
core modules and each one is developed
and designed to help you overcome the
most common challenges that hold people
back module one is core it's about
figuring out what is core for you and
helping you design the life that you
deserve so day one is inspiration day
two is motivation d3 is values day four
is purpose and day five is goals module
two is we're gonna help you develop an
unstoppable mindset day six gonna help
you believe day seven you're gonna get
more courage they eight we're gonna give
you more self-love day nine we're gonna
help you develop your discipline and day
ten we're gonna build your confidence
module three is about helping you
overcome from the biggest challenges
that hold people back so day eleven
we're gonna overcome fear day 12 are
gonna overcome stress day 13 we're gonna
overcome our haters day 14 we're gonna
overcome our failures and day 15 we're
gonna overcome procrastination module 4
then talks about how to build the habits
that you need to become a success so day
16 we're gonna look at your morning
routine day 17 we're gonna boost your
productivity day 18 we're gonna help you
identify your priorities day 19 we're
gonna talk about developing a reading
habit and day 20 we're gonna look at
your evening routine then we move into
module 5 which is about starting up your
business and having more financial
success so day 21 is about generating
ideas that will make you money day 22
will help you improve your sales skills
D 23 will help you improve your branding
skills day 24 will help you improve your
marketing skills and day 25 will help
you improve your persuasion skills and
then the last module module 6 is about
growth it's about helping you now play a
much bigger game in your business and in
your life so day 26 is about thinking
bigger day 27 is about hiring and
building your team day 28 is about
becoming a much better leader for
yourself and the people around you
day 29 is about you becoming a speaker
and spreading your message
and day 30 is about how to have the
consistency you need so that you follow
through and achieve your goals so how
many of those areas are holding you back
now really think about it those areas
how many of them if you could fix would
have a dramatic impact on your life on
your business on the people around you
what would your life look like if those
things were not holding you back any
longer that's the goal with best life 30
30 days of insane info from the hundred
thousand videos that we've watched that
you can make the ship that you need in
your life again we start for free
tomorrow on the main channel but if you
want to make sure you don't miss a video
and get the companion worksheets click
the link in description go sign up 100%
free I can't wait to start with you
tomorrow okay before we go though we've
got a bunch of free bonuses as well now
when I told people about it they said
wait free bonuses for a free program and
yes the value in the 30 days is
incredible it's gonna be some of my best
work but this is so important to me
again the challenge was if I could not
produce a video on YouTube ever again I
had 30 more days to do it this is the
series that will define me and have a
long lasting impact so I had to make it
as valuable as possible so bonus number
one is the PDF companion worksheets so
with every video that you watch there is
a companion worksheet that again you get
for free that is 10 to 12 pages long
each one really helping you take notes
on the videos that you're watching and
ask you thought-provoking questions to
help you get the shift that you need to
overcome those challenges I don't want
you to just watch another video this is
really important to me I don't want you
to just watch another YouTube video and
feel motivated in the moment I want you
to get results and shift your life so
watch the video do the exercises and
shift your life I'm trying to make it as
easy as possible for you to get the
results you want and also eliminate the
excuses in your head now after the 30
days I'm also adding in 7 bonus videos
again 100% free based on more personal
topics to help you make the next shift
so here's we're gonna cover in the bonus
videos day 31 is about how do you figure
out the balance that you need to have in
your life in your personal in your
business how do you match it all
together and feel like your life is in
balance day 32 is about getting the
right sleep and designing the routine so
you get enough sleep to
your life date 33 is about diet making
sure that you're healthy that you're
able to have the energy to go off and
build the business that you want in the
life that you deserve day 34 is about
exercise and how to stay motivated and
how to create a routine that builds you
up so that you can build this life not
just for what you're doing right now but
for decades to come
date 35 is about relationships and how
to have a higher quality relationship
with your significant other but also the
other people in your life day 36 is
about investing and how to when you
start making some money make sure that
you're invested in things that continue
to make money not just for yourself but
for future generations of your family
and day 37 is going to be about
meditation where we look at how you can
get that calmness that stillness and
relieve the stress from your life so
that you can make more calm rational
decisions to build the best life
possible for yourself for your family
and for the people around you so those
are the bonuses the world's leading
experts and your heroes weighing in on
the topics that you care about that can
shift your life forward every day for
the next 30 days
are you excited as I am that's like 30
it's coming we start tomorrow now change
isn't easy for me for you for anyone
change is not easy but for those of us
who are willing to put in the time and
the effort and the work it does happen
the ship can happen for you so I'm so
excited for you to join best life 30
join the program and you too get the
ship that you deserve that you want to
make right now in your life and move
forward so one last time there's a link
in the description 100% free go click on
it it'll make sure that you never miss a
video in the 30 you get all the bonuses
you get the companion worksheet to get
these seven extra bonuses as well go in
there I really want to make sure that
you get this value and that we make the
ship together we're about to go on this
journey best live 30 let's make it
happen I can't wait to see you tomorrow
continue to believe and let's go PS if
you're excited to join give me a hashtag
best live 30 in the comments below
and we made it even easier to sign up
there's a link right there under me go
click it sign up and I'll see you
tomorrow